talked about a researcher named timothy
pitchell who's done quite a lot of
research into the subject of
procrastination and one of the studies
that he did examined the role of guilt
and procrastination and the forgiveness
of that guilt when he surveyed 119
college students he found that students
who took the time to deliberately
forgive themselves for procrastination
in preparation for a midterm exam we're
actually less likely to procrastinate on
future exams so before you get into any
of the other steps in this process if
you are a chronic procrastinator if
you've been kicking yourself for wasting
tons of time first forgive yourself and
it's also useful to realize that going
forward there is never going to be a
perfect moment to study there's never
going to be a perfect time to do it and
this is one of the stories we tell
ourselves right we think that in the
future things are going to be better the
stars are going to be aligned and we're
going to be at a much better position to
actually get to work and what you have
to do is tell yourself that this moment
right now it's imperfect it's not
exactly what you want it to be but it is
passable it's enough for you to get to
work and at least make some progress